began to play me call kar 1985 yeah
frequent frequent do all I think we have
discussed the names Oh earlier I
remember there was a game where he
played the absolute main line with you
three yeah 32 and so on hmm okay summer
I have not played a 5mm did I forget
that move maybe here i can go d phi
however at least i believe that there
should be okay he usually white usually
goes to d3 to make sure that d5 is not
happening okay that's interesting i have
d for now okay move more first think
later so do i want to take only 3 or is
there anything better Nyjah phone okay
let's not spend a GM and play quickly it
splits jazz be sure before I go check
and take with the Queen I was thinking
g3 Queen checks that's pretty okay why
is Bishop g4 even better I can cancel
okay of course you can also cancel but I
felt that in comparison this this looks
better okay um what am I doing here but
should be six or just developing or do I
have anything better
his king is slightly weak not sure about
it let's do this book just looking at
the sea for pound a little bit yeah
we're thinking night f5 that's good just
attacking see for quite a lot oh just
take their y SI out form look at four
okay for i have Queenie to word
left we need to at least a whole or
anything better even
now I can see does the simple thing okay
still trying for a little something okay
of 62 yeah it's equal material of course
the question is can I somehow somehow
get on the long diagonal down Queen to
e4 Bishop to g5 this would be excellent
anyway to do that my queen is really
wrong for the heads food maybe maybe
start with this move yes look at four
that's that's really irritating yeah but
anyway maybe I can get queen bee three
and look f4 and then g5 just forcing
that Rahman recoger 60 k is covering
covering d3 and maybe a aiming for Roxy
one let's do this so Roxy one between be
five and now bishops is 6 for 25 that
would do if that hits it gets gets ugly
so queenie queenie too probably yeah yes
to trade queens okay this is rather
George the only thing you can try to
sacrifice on c6 if everything works out
ideal live for him I think I'm trying to
prevent that maybe Bishop here so that
looks it towards not possible i think
i'm offering a droid honored okay I can
try he has this symbolic advantage let's
say with the with this look on the
seventh and so on it's nothing nothing
serious at all but he's got more time of
course more time on the clock Jeff
Luke c5 I don't know check if I used too
much time and also we heard me J
check check I mean the position is
already better for black but I have no
time so I'm conservative here i will
take a repetition and I mean better for
black does not mean I am winning or so I
just anybody can do something that's
probably me but still very dry
see going for what looks before I don't
don't really get it check check my king
elective here don't mind that check time
warning
Bishop before let's look do you one
double check or whatever check
this is this is still a pin huh
we hope I'm not killing myself over
something stupid after he has pledged us
completely suicidal game okay white
resigns he's just nothing happening and
then he just gave me everything with the
Jeep horn and everything I offered to
draw I mean it really just just dad
really the only thing as i said is him
him opening for me playing Bishop c6 and
sacrificing but I think it just is just
a dead position check check check
children no I mean the g1 is dangerous
check check check it's still probably
okay for a long long time check Chad
installed gives an equal and now I'm
winning roop th seems to be a draw check
check yeah this is a perpetual check hmm
Jen check dg2 okay can take G to him of
course it was playing for this this
Bishop before things but I think they
they weren't working right check through
go to his winning hmm yeah very tricky
business but I think he probably just
wanted too much there it's a little bit
like I sometimes lose the game sep
trying to win with some ideas and it
just does not work okay well thanks for
watching